the entire cast recently got back
together 10 years after the show's debut
to relive the good times and the bad bad
fashions with our Lee Ann Aguilera my
first day shooting on the pilot we shot
the scene where Betty comes out in the
hot pants in the pilot and join so that
was our first scene do you remember like
the models were really mean the cast
reunited at the ATX Television Festival
in Austin Texas
hosted by Entertainment Weekly it was so
different than what was gonna be seen on
TV that I didn't think that it was gonna
get picked up because it was so unique
there was nothing else like it what was
it like having those braces on all those
years America the hilarity of it is the
day that we were gonna shoot Betty's
real mouth my mouth in rehearsal at 6:00
in the morning I ran into of unto a
mannequin and chipped my tooth Ugly
Betty still lives on today streaming on
Hulu but what about a reboot
y'all be interested in an Ugly Betty
continuation of any form we were first
dibs
you know they get a first look deal on
our two-hour movie special that we're
declaring right now and I'm making this
out one of America's favorite episodes
was her TV sister Ana Ortiz getting
hitched to Adam Rodriguez
thank you what was it about shooting
that wedding that was so emotional for
you whenever anything emotional happened
on the show it felt like yes these
characters but it also was us and it was
our family et was on the set 15 times
and we even captured the epic catfight
between Vanessa Williams and Judith
Light and I don't know by that's clean
ah it was the most fun and of course
because we know each other we knew that
we were going to be safe with each other
so nothing was going to happen we had
such a good time
you